[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
day four in London reverted to possible
chess as we started the grand chest tour
finals Hikaru Nakamura took the bull by
the horns jumping straight into one of
Maxine's asurela graft specialties this
seemed to backfire as only a few moves
after the opening was cleared the black
was her choice after missing one precise
move to put real pressure on his
opponent MVL wasn't able to find a good
continuation and the game was drawn in
the consolation match between Fabiano
Khurana and Levon Aronian the American
found himself quickly in hot water to
precise maneuvering and razor short
calculation the runner kept his position
together and salvaged a before the last
classical chess game in London starts
now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to day five of the London chest
classic we're here at the Royal Air
Force Bomber Command memorial dedicated
to the other fifty thousand of these
Airmen that gave their lives in World
War two for our players it's the last
day of classical chess and let's see
what kind of risks they take over the
board for all the action we go to our
studio in st. Louis
Thank You alejandro i'm jennifer Tejada
and I'm here with Grandmaster gasser so
on for the final classical game of the
year at least at the elite level
certainly feels that way doesn't it
Jenna pleasure is always to be with you
I had the classical chess have not seen
any decisive games thus far in the grand
chest Tour Finals Jen and Vasilisa this
is it this is our last day of classical
chess well today could be the day let's
take a look at our results so far we've
got two drawled so far in the classical
that means that Hikaru Nakamura and
Maxine Bachelor of our finals match
started with a draw as did Levon Aronian
it's a game against Viviano Carolina
although in both games there seems like
there was lots of chances for the black
side indeed and our current schedule
with two days remaining well today again
it's the last possible game and then we
go to wrapping and blitzen monday
starting at 2 p.m. London that's 9 a.m.
on the East Coast 8 a.m. here in st.
Louis so be sure to block up some time
in your calendar for that and the format
for tomorrow well as we see today we're
wrapping up the classic in each game is
worth 6 points if we get to wrapping him
when we get to wrap it in blitz we're
gonna have two games of rapid where it's
four points each and four games of blitz
worth 2 points each so mathematicians
like Maxime Bashara like Rob can really
strategize here if I lose what do I need
to do if I win how can i maybe avoid
some risks and maximize my chances of
taking home the title exactly 6 points
up for grabs
we've got grandmaster Maurice Ashley to
take us a trip down a memory lane of
Grantchester 2018 well indeed 2018 is
soon coming to a close and it's a time
for fun and
and family and also time for reflection
how did the year ago well we will
reflect on how the year is gone for the
Grantchester how our four competitors
got here first of all let's start with
living in Belgium where Wesley so won
that tournament staking his claim but
take a look at the three players LaVon
and Maxime and Hikaru who finished in
the top half of the competition you want
to be in that position throughout as you
play but famously Fabiano Caruana
finished in ninth place while moving on
to Paris and it was Hikaru Nakamura
surging to the top showing his dominance
while again LaVon and Maxime finishing
in the top half and again Fabiano
finishing in ninth that is not the way
you want to get here well how did he
make a comeback well let's first of all
start with a st. Louis rapid and blitz
where who karo basically staked his
claim to London he said that's it I'm
probably not gonna need the next event
after dominating Maxime also put himself
in a fantastic position by coming in
second and there you see Fabiano caruana
what a great event finishing in 4th
again Levon
top half always never below it and
finally the Sinquefield Cup where a lot
was decided first of all Fabi needed to
win it all and he tied for first with
LaVon that sentient full Devon Maxime of
course outside the top half but barely
so enough to get him in the position to
be here in London and Hikaru had a
disastrous event and still qualified in
that classical and the final standings
we see you Kara there despite the
Sinquefield cup disastrous result Levon
of course tying it with the Sinquefield
cup that was able to show that he's as
clearly ahead Maxime also way ahead of
the pack and there's far be tied with
Wesley so and having to win that tie
break play-off against Wesley and that's
how he got to London and so we are here
now with four players and we'll see just
how they fare as this final classical
game classical matchups of the year for
the elite level and to give us some more
thoughts on that let's jump to London
with Grandmaster Alejandro Reyes
Thank You Maurice we are here indeed in
the western side of London and yesterday
we had quite a jovial evening we went
out to a section his restaurant referred
about 15 people there including the play
some of the players some chest
journalists we had excellent food we had
laughs we had a good a couple of drinks
but there was one person that was
missing there from that group he Cara
Nakamura knows that he has to be all
business today as he is facing Maxime
vassella graph with the black pieces
lost today would be absolutely
disastrous remember that tomorrow plays
against the number one player in the
world in blitz Maxime said that Magnus
is still a better player but that's up
to debate us
it's MVL that's sitting at over twenty
nine fifty and he karna come where I
knows this is a crucial game would the
black pieces he cannot lose against
Maxime holograph who will definitely be
trying to apply pressure pressure with a
white pieces Thank You alejandro and
jennifer big prize money lots of
stocking stuffers for what you want in
your stocking 200k in that final bag
120k and hundred thousand dollars in the
third-place match as well as was
announced yesterday a spot into the 2019
tour both players very likely to make it
in some other way but hey why not just
secure it lock it up and this is what
Nakamura is fighting for that's one
reason why you cannot go to that dinner
this is serious business it's not just
the money it's also the title and based
on what you said yesterday guys I got to
think that you're cheering Nakamura is
serious attitude yeah conspicuously
absent there's a little partying
you can always party you know like after
the event is over and yeah I like his
seriousness well yeah the thing is
there's partying on in in person but
there's even like enjoying and partying
online as we were debating yesterday
right about these these two extremes and
all these other fun things that naka
does exactly really doing all of them in
one tournament would be a little
overwhelming right even
Cara's multitasking abilities that would
be a little bit too much to ask and here
we see Levon Aronian and charming as
ever talking to some journalists for
students but no doubt we're dallying the
mall with his legendary charms and you
know LaVon just such a chill person he's
really happy to talk to anyone yeah one
of the things I've always remarked about
LaVon is a great ambassador for not only
chest but Armenia and wherever he goes
there seems to be in Armenian community
and they turn out in moss when he's in
town oh yeah he's got a lot of I would
like to give a shout out to the Russian
show Peter stood there and Miro over in
Studio B talking about these games in
Russian and I did use my Google trusty
Google Translate again for Peter just
tweet promoting today's show which is
always gives me some laughs
he says 18 out of 18 there are only two
left
well any of the participants in the fine
will be able to break the London curse
me and Mauro are ready to knuckle
expecto Berlin him so I can only imagine
what enough to expect Oh Berlin immunity
[Music]
yeah as well behind
Malcolm Payne the organizer in London
and the word London curse at the sounds
local air to London yet of course here
in the seat filled cup there were very
few victories I think it was 8 out of 45
games I mean that percentages is through
muffins and rose obviously a bit better
than London clearly better than London
into classical games anyway as we've had
just zero 100 percent draws but there's
just few games or a lot fewer games so
very small sample size not really fair
to London as now LaVon is finished with
all the fraternizing and and
picture-taking and it's time to get down
to business
he is playing against Fabiano Caruana we
talked
about that third place pot very
important and also that extra 20 grand
you know it's kind of funny that you
could win $40,000 and seem like you
failed I mean you don't think you don't
you come in last and then you don't
qualify for next year's title next
year's tour immediately but it what it's
gonna be you know negative feeling going
on in the players if they anybody who
comes in fourth you know you know you
never want to lose the consolation you
know and especially at the very end of
the year years and the last competition
you really want to do very well and
there we see Malcolm Payne getting ready
to introduce the players and final day
of classical also guys quick time for a
poll are we gonna break the curse sounds
strong gonna be strong are we gonna
break the streak this draws that we're
seeing two draws my it's been wild gosh
I think less than 50% I mean how can you
talk too much
always yeah I mean it's it's at this
level
generally speaking well two with two
games well generally speaking with with
chess the fan should note that a lot of
calculations have been done around
chassis say prevalence of draws well if
you go above the 2700 level then white
generally wins about 35% of the time
black points about 25% of the time and
and draws results 40% of the time so as
far as White's concerned and pretty
healthy score knowing that you generally
will not lose in those matchups there
because you you only lose 25% of the
time so those who have white feel a bit
more secure whenever they're sitting
across the board but black also knows
they only lose only 35% of the time but
that's that you mentioned have got to be
for like 27 hundred plus twenty eight
hundred plus B right if you start at the
2700 level and you know that's the case
imagine if a player is now twenty seven
fifty 2775 2800 even more so you feel
like when I sit down at the board
especially as white those guys are
thinking it's gonna be to two times out
of ten maybe I'll lose the game and if I
don't even want to try that's another
point as well because we're talking
about games that these fighters are
really going at it in a lot of those
cases but if I don't want to try no so
we'll see but we do have Malcolm Payne
in London on stage right now hello
everyone and welcome to the Olympia
conference centre here in London for day
two of the Grantchester 2018 finals I'm
Malcolm Payne from the charity chess in
schools and communities which delivers
chess to over 25,000 children in state
schools around the United Kingdom and
organizes the London chess classic I
particularly like to thank our sponsors
the lohia foundation new sponsor this
year deep mind who accommodated us for
the semifinals so wonderfully and we
really enjoyed being there and of course
the st. Louis chess club without whom
the Grantchester would probably never
have got off the ground so with the
scores in the final matches at three
three after the first classical game
let's welcome the players onto the stage
contesting the battle for third place
with $100,000 at stake would you please
welcome Levon Aronian and Fabiano Cara
Juana
[Applause]
and fighting it out for the title of
grand chest tall champion 2018 with
$200,000 at stake
please welcome Hikaru Nakamura and
maxeen Vasily Groff and because the
tournament is run by chess in schools
charity as all of you watching here and
on the Internet will know it's a
tradition at the London Chest I think
that the ceremonial first move is made
by one of the young people here at the
London chess classic either those who
come for the school's activities are
playing in the tournament and today I'm
really really pleased to welcome a young
man who learnt chess through the charity
at a school in the London borough of
newham became an extremely strong player
so good in fact that he's represented
England at junior level and he's playing
in the tournament the other tournaments
that are taking place alongside the
Grantchester here at Olympia please
welcome Joshua John
[Applause]
so Joshua's gonna make the first move
for Maxine
well Joshua we've seen quite a few of
your games on Ches pace so I know you
play several different opening moves
which one would you like to propose one
d4
maxime Joshua thank you very much and
and so I'll leave it to the arbiters to
get the games underway thank you and
thank you Malcolm Payne as we get ready
to start so far I think the kids are one
out of five in classical chess and
pretty much better e to e for by MVL to
get the game underway and E five not a
Petrov potentially Berlin or Joko piano
Bishop c4 Berlin against Aronian in the
rapid he won a very very nice game
indeed so here we go I don't think
there's any reason at all for Hikaru to
take a chance black pieces and yellow is
one of the players who does go directly
into the ending after d4 yeah a lot of
players are now avoiding the ending with
rook e1 in other moves but video has
been very consistent and going directly
into the sending in genuine mentioning
the other day that you just don't say
you're unhappy when you see it too often
exactly it's been a while now we've seen
it twice maybe maybe but I do see
do you feel a little bit more and it's
also imbalanced I mean of course it was
very annoying like when there were three
games and in the tournament
yes but it is actually quite imbalance
so it's right I think it could be it
could be well there's only two games the
other one is a petrov by the way that's
going on in the consolation match and
look at how fast they are just my
goodness did they have to be a word that
there is a 30-second delay after all
that's okay I mean even if there is a
delay if the moves are memorized they
figure why not just go with it right go
pass exactly and here we're looking at
the game between LaVon and Fabiano and
Fabiano is a vaunted petrov has now been
played against magnus carlsen he carves
Nakamura Levon Aronian everybody is
getting a crack with the white pieces
but can anybody dent this extremely
solid petrov fabi's played with the
black pieces has really been
extraordinary
I mean indeed you look at his openings
Magnus couldn't break him down in any of
those games in many cases Magnus was
running away from some of those
positions we remember rook d8
yes in the World Championship and Magnus
had an expletive and to say when he said
he saw that move line on the board whoa
what's going on here and and he bagged
down a couple of times against Bobbi's
ferocious novelties I say ferocious just
means lose that you don't expect to see
and suddenly they're working on the
board and he was able to prove that a
black is more than okay so where do you
go after him as he has been just fully
armed so that I neutralized White's
initiative exactly and here is from the
Petrov let's listen take it from the top
very very quickly he fortified the
petrov and these days Knight c3 is the
main move I mean everybody it seems has
played Knight c3
issuing the much older
much more common d4 and they very
quickly get into this position where
both sides are castled on opposite
flanks you'll remember Jen that if the
scene fell Cup we had this Bishop c4
this very early Bishop c4 by Magnus
Carlsen
and what fabbi has been doing recently
in from the Berlin as well as the world
championship matches instead of bringing
his knight to f6 very quickly he's reset
his pawn in the center on the c6 and D 5
squares Bishop d3 if Maurice asked us or
was it you who asked to predict the
chances of a decisive game today after
the openings whatever your other words
got to be a little lower I got to be a
lot lower now yeah at the moment because
both black players are playing the most
solid defenses to 1.e4 and here I was
just expecting the move Knight c5 and
after a little delay a little bit
surprising delay I must say 95 was
eventually played by Fabiano as with
this bishop on d3 eyeballing a potential
sacrifice on the h7 we often see why
playing the move h4 in conjunction with
Bishop d3 we believe h4 is on the board
h4 is on the board 83 quickly play yes
because once again Bishop takes h7
checked Knight g5 checks these are the
types of sacrifices that black wants to
avoid mean it avoids them very well
indeed by simply eliminating this very
good Bishop on d3 and we're expecting
Queen takes d3
okay just to mention that in case of
ponch captures d3 this bishop could come
nicely to the Kings side either with
Bishop f6 followed by Bishop f5 or
Bishop f5 immediately I think they're
both good Queen takes d3 stops this
bishop from coming to fi but oh yeah no
I'm just it I mean it it seems like
White's putting all of his I want to say
all of his eggs behind Knight g5 to try
to get something on the King side but it
just feels like there's there's not
enough in this position Queen d6 this is
a very good defensive play because the
idea is this if you go Knight g5 hoping
to force something g6 or something of
that nature stops being better in these
types of situations because I'm gonna go
Bishop f5 and once I get my certain a
certain bishops and why not right
so what Queen d6 is the last turn of
Fabiano and again you know if you go
Knight d4 with the idea f3 and g4 it
really is looking slow and again Queen
g6 might be a very good way of
neutralizing the situation let's just
turn back to the finals tables and who
somehow whites Queen psyche just got
mangled let's see how that happened Jen
well we got right into this a famous
Berlin ending Keaney ain't one of the
older moves this all looks like the
match between Magnus Carlsen and Vishy
Anand this seems to all be very standard
stuff and that's how whites Queen site
structure got dinged was the capture and
very quickly are we all still in theory
we just exited in fact a very popular
position for not just my theory you're
talking about all the top players having
experimented in this line I'm talking
about names like car yeah convey Sheila
Grubb Kramnik Topalov and of course
Nakamura on this list as well and in
fact this exact position has been seen
before in Nakamura practice after rook F
to e one Bishop to b4 and as you call it
the mangling with the move a three on
this side of the board g4 has been
played before but Nakamura himself faced
this against one Sergei Kuryakin right
here in st. Louis this year in blitz and
he ended up losing at that game against
Sergei well Sergei also faced this
position in rapid against Vasily Grove
and he managed to draw the game in this
position he played differently however
he played rook a to d8 in this game
Nakamura when he faced it the first time
played rook to g6 but this time he had a
new wrinkle to move h4 so if we jump
back to the game position you see here
after BC 3 instead of rook g60 starts
with the move h4 restraining white on
that side Maxime seems ready for though
he instantly played 90 for route g6 and
now G for anyway H es 3 ft FG 3 and talk
about a pawn structure that only a
mother could love this position just
looks awful in terms of whites formation
and the opposite colored bishops black
looks very solid here but there's
something about this that Maxime really
likes it must be the space on this side
there's still the three-two to that
white is hoping he'll be able to somehow
make some haywith but certainly not your
traditional pawn structure that you
hotel your students to adopt well at the
highest level they come up with a lot of
curious ideas this pawn structure stops
this four against three anyway so he's
not worried about that and also not
worried about losing these guys on this
side of the board we'll see whether he
can make some kind of pressure in this
endgame yeah
I understand that from whites point of
view he does want he does have a plan
okay
on a good day let's just imagine what
his plan might be if we imagine the
position after g4 and something like
this right if you take a look at that
rook it could it does have the potential
of being somewhat trapped like
artificially isolated how how will black
ever get his rook back into play flights
intention is to play for example some
moves like King f2 and King f3 and
slowly slowly use his King sight pawn
structure to advantage so I can't
imagine that there is the potential of
wayward rook now having said that what
what to do when black plays moves like
Bishop d5 and rookie six bring that
wayward rook into play that's something
for Maxime to decide can he get an edge
here it's it's going to be a challenge
Maurice terrible in terms of getting in
advantage I mean yeah really you look at
this the pawn structure a looks that is
an ugly sole battery yeah the rook is
not isolated pawn their Bishop e5 looks
perfectly fine isolated pawn the only
the only thing I could feel about this
position is that night that night on f5
yeah will be kicked eventually and gee
where we'll have to live in the long
term mm-hmm you so there is the
potential for expansion but like your
move for example Bishop d5 with the idea
of the looks fixed and maybe looks
fairly straightforward right looks like
a plan let's go of getting this piece
somewhere and this is the main question
I would put my knight back on e7
naturally
yeah and so more or less I you know I
don't know how why and how but somehow
in these Berlin's where white can escort
his pawns push his pawns up the board
with his King on g3 that seems to be the
place to put the king okay but what
happens if if we figure out a way to
start addressing your epoch something
like King f8 looks a king to f8 okay hmm
well you haven't captured my knight
right I could have done it on the last
movement then come on but then I can't
play King f8 because there's also the
idea of trading rooks and putting a rook
on d6 and a night on jisuk this is what
I'm thinking about
we're going six a night on g6 over just
really and then go Knight to g6 yeah and
then I can also go to d5 my timing could
work out just right right once I trade
well let's see how how that timing could
potentially work in your favor so let's
say I play rook d3 to ETA so I'm
thinking that you're gonna capture my
knight put your knight on g6
I'll go Knight to g5 first of all again
I'm looking to artificially isolate the
rook yes and there's another there's an
issue if you could play six just for fun
at some moment yeah I'm not watchful in
principle I think it's nice
if white does get an opportunity to
trade the e5 pawn for the c7 pawn the
position opens up but I have to make
sure that I'm going to be better
developed to take advantage of that
active situation let's go back a move
let's go back here you played this is
actually
let's play the most straightforward way
okay let's play the most free forward
way so did you like keep liking f - yeah
Bishop e5 you only think I went here
here here yes let's play the most boring
way possible let's take on e4 let's see
what this ending looks like okay take
stakes and if I play you want to take
your knight on d5 now instead of G say
no I was gonna play rook d8 I was gonna
trade off another pair of rooks test
this ending but I'm afraid of route d4
should I be worried about this move rook
to David but but I'm not sure I need to
be afraid of this idea for sure you
don't want to help my pawn structure but
here I was thinking that again I I
wanted to artificially isolate your look
Maurice takes takes let's say King f3 so
okay rookie 6 rookie 6 excuse me and
let's go so I could get my pawns to age
five and maybe c4 I'm trying to play
against Knight is it is it enough though
I know that in many many cases of the
Berlin defence one way you can play for
an for black is to play this move c5 and
the rook comes swinging across to the
ACE X square and because you dinged up
the mangled the queen size structure you
can play to attack the pawn on a3
another idea is b5 so King f3 b5k the
idea behind that is to secure the
outpost d5 so that you can meet c4 well
though I really I'm headed to see for my
knight is going d5 d6 c4 what's my
intent in my original intent get my
knight of another square with some
activity as well and if you play for see
for yourself then you
could go the other way to the sea force
I can get if I can somehow convince you
to exactly but but even here there's
some dynamics for white though are like
the bishop in this position because it
seemed like a pawn with an ornate six
with effect so we're seeing the Indian
place off out with h4h 585 and I think
you're looking for them yes and so for
this age pawn to go down the board
exactly this is this is no doubt what he
sees as the salient feature in the
position it's a fact that someday he'll
play h5g v h6 etc and it's a dark square
h8 is a dark square so is promoting on a
dark square well if you can ever get
that eight past HP engine and use the
three versus two majority in the Berlin
it is genuinely a nice advantage for
white let's just take a quick look at
the betrothed game has got a got in the
movie for getting rid of those double
ponds Texas uh-huh so we have left it
just after ninety three takes d3 we were
eyeballing a chance for Knight g5 and
that was why Queen d6 was played and and
now LaVon seize the moment to get this
move c-4 in because he's taking
advantage of the fact there is a pin
along the D file and after 48 C takes d5
and fabi's and move trying to decide
what to take with here you can take with
the Queen because there's no real
effective discoveries it looks like okay
and that certainly has my vote Queen
takes d5 but then after Queen takes d5
one way or the other you are gonna get
that imbalance of an isolated pawn for
the two bishops and what what are your
thoughts on that is easy draw neither
player is going to be better I mean it's
just it's just that after after
something like this you've always got to
consider the fact that well first of all
this
on the singing I better be careful about
losing that the two bishops is just
simply compensation enough look like
Avon is very ambitious in this game yes
and I think maybe it goes back into that
same philosophy of Magnus and Nakamura
that he thinks he maybe has an edge and
the faster games absolutely he's
speeding towards rapid and blitz
well there you go I mean but on the
other hand it's just very strange way of
throwing away the white pieces throwing
away you don't get anything with white
pieces and then you made a very
important point that if in this format
might promote some of this kind of I
want to say waffling throwing
marshmallows 50 feet as you call it yeah
it's not hand-to-hand combat but
basically here the players are saying
this guy's not that good at rapid a
blitz I mean they're they're just
shouting it this guy is not that good at
I say for the marshmallow they're saying
yeah wait till we get to rapid and blitz
and we're gonna have some fun with you
and make your calculations because
you're so good at classical that we know
why play chess in this place with you
know let's go to where we know you're
weaker clearly Robbie's virtually tied
for first is no more playing the world
nuclear number 2 player on the planet
you don't have to fight him here you
don't fight him here that's simply
what's being said right now and
unfortunately that's what we're seeing
in these in this rapid and in these
classical games against Fabi nobody
wants to face face off against its
tremendous preparation against positions
that he just plays when he's comfortable
well well unfortunately for the fans but
for Fabi playing the black pieces that's
that's the problem it's like they and I
pointed out the the issue for me is that
in these hybrid formats you would think
that if somebody has an edge in the
in the rapid and they're trying to play
for a draw consequently there should be
an equilibrium where the other player
doesn't want that to happen but because
especially with the black pieces in
chess it's very hard you know take the
huge risk and also because of the
confidence effect of anybody at this
level they're not they're not gonna
agree they go yeah I'm just gonna get
killed in blitz no we've had some great
booths results as well so somehow it
doesn't there's no counter effect
there's an effect that sometimes people
are playing for a draw but doesn't seem
that there's a strong counter effect
that like if you looked at it from a
theory point of view you would expect
there to be and I'm not quite sure
exactly why that is if it's more because
of the nature of chess or it's more
because of the nature of confidence if
you're already at this level yeah well I
was just thinking about Murray says he
we opened up the show and he was talking
about how did the players get here and
you saw that in Paris and Leuven ninth
place by Fabiano
and only he was very very fortunate in
the st. Louis rapid and blitz to score
one point more then did LaVon
because that put him in the in the
situation at the same field Cup where
once he tied for first with LaVon and
with Magnus he could get into that
playoff with Wesley excuse me it was
very important that Wesley didn't do
well also huge because was it's Wesley
only getting 26 any little bit more
why's that because Wesley had won Lubin
right so he'd gotten a full 13 points in
one event
Wesley then only scored 13 points in the
next three total to get to only 26 think
about the fall-off he had in after such
a spectacular start in Leuven so Robbie
was very fortunate even to make it here
with this combination format of rapid
and blitz and classical he showed in the
st. Louis trapping them in the sink
field cup hey you classical games I got
no problems but he absolutely struggled
in the other format and it's showing
once again that the players believed
that he will struggle
and strategically when you play Fabi if
you've got a hybrid format just
neutralize this classical game and take
him on in a rapid and blitz and it makes
so much sense to do that you'd almost be
stupid not to do it it's it's like why
would you if you're LaVon why would you
say let me go all guns blazing you know
man where the other guy far-out rates be
far our rates by the way mean it's about
sixty rating points between them no Wow
something like that why would you do
that when the guys so comfortable he's
preparation so fantastic when you can
take him someplace else where your
consensus no doubt gonna be he's gonna
be worse than you exactly
well yeah you put it like that I mean
it's pretty straightforward get to the
rapid and blitz and get there quickly
by the way surprising for me Jen as in
the game between LaVon and fabbi after
the trade of Queens we didn't see a
trade of rooks rather c6 takes d5 was
fab ease for sure because of the well
threat of Bishop g4 might be too strong
that I will I wanted to put my knight on
d4 I'm eyeballing Knight b5 which hits
the pawn on a7 as well as 97 which would
fork the rook and the d5 pawn so 94
I don't know Bishop d7 perhaps what do
you think all very very good stuff no
indeed and then I'm gonna borrow a page
from the PlayBook of Magnus Carlsen
remember what
what you're saying well maybe h5 then go
for g4 h5 also H is something also to be
said for h5 Murray's right starting so
that you get 816 before you start the
hook right let's look at the breakdown
of these two with the faster game does
you see actually LaVon does not have an
edge so far in their matchups in blitz
although that's not a large number of
games only six games or Rapids all right
well it actually is in fat B's favorite
yeah and that and certainly that makes
sense by the way in the universal rating
system they're actually really very
close I checked yesterday and I believe
it was fourth and fifth with Bobby and
fourth and LaVon and fifth so yeah just
incredibly to well match players here
although I think psychologically that
may it's a moment in time right we're
talking about Bobby just lost a rapid
match against Magnus horribly then he
just lost again to Nakamura pretty badly
right now
Ravana say well when you got a kick and
while they're down yeah maybe next year
he'll get some confidence right right
now
kick him while he's down because he
hasn't done well in the last few weeks
in any rapid inlets matches so Wells
take him there is Fabi thinking the same
let me avoid just easily drawing that
position you were talking about take
with the rook get pieces off the board
and and go into the Rapidan blitz or is
he thinking nard I'm gonna try to win
this game
when mmm why did he take with the
partner so the red eye I'm still
confused about the only explanation I
might have is that had he tried he
captured right away with the rook rook
takes rook takes pawn takes let's say
rook to d1 he saw that this rook coming
to d1 white gets to do that with a with
tempo in other words the rook on d1 has
been traded for the rook on d8 and he
might have thought okay by preserving
the rooks from the very start I'll deny
this rook coming over but now having
said that I mean he's the one with the
pawn weakness
so if you can trade off pieces that
would attack the pawn weakness the
opponent is not going to be weak at all
absolutely so it is a little bit I'm a
little bit thrown back it's a risky move
it is wonder why he is he is he feeling
the doubt himself let's be clear you say
you like it I'm sorry every time you say
you like something rapid match Bobby you
got this exciting position yeah this is
exciting
be careful just gaining activity just
for activity sake this is a dangerous
territory testing these top players by
saying yeah you know I'm gonna keep it
funky they know how tough the other
player is and when you start mixing it
up and a lot of writers say well you
should throw you some risk Lucy some
risk risk this you know you know what
you're playing you try to be risky they
see through all this stuff it's not just
risk Forrest sake you cannot do that
against these guys they've seen just
about everything and you've got to play
the right positional move and decide is
this the right thing to do right now
because you might feel in a you know
with him mixing it up in about six or
seven moves you might say well I'm not
really sure I like this position very
much why did I mix it up after all well
hold on what happened after night well
yeah exactly you you've got to take this
the threat of night b5 quite seriously
like for example let's say you just make
a bad move Knight b5 comes with effect
this pawn on a7 would be lost or ninety
seven once again would fall the rook and
the d5 pawn so I was thinking you're
gonna go Bishop a7 and when
like 97 oh yeah so for example hello
first yes and then you capture the
exchange as you say so Bishop d7 was -
it was aimed at preventing the move 95
and then you said 93 immediately okay
f5 ethics I don't really want to put it
on c6 that much because that well cuz
then I if I ever play rook c8 and
blocking my own file it's so I'm
thinking I want to keep it on that c8 g
4 diagonal well certainly this is the
most active right if you yeah if you
were thinking that oh boy I want to you
know in a like in Sicilian fashion I
want to use the C file then you would
think that okay maybe the bishop is 94
and guess what Bishop d7 we've seen you
getting your Bishop tract so you
actually are can help me to play Bishop
d7 and then you know we could
potentially see just a quick repetition
if if white chose oh can wait try
something else after maybe three after
Knight b3 Bishop f5 we do have Bishop
what else is there here's or something
with like no you 94 back on the board
that I was right about something yeah
that cynical way of just going directly
marry on the board again and we're
seeing for rapid and blitz maybe if he's
gonna differ at this moment it's gonna
be now because I think once you play
Knight b3 Bishop f5 like rook c8 could
be
coming you wanna you want to put that
night back on before yeah so if there's
some moment to change your mind now now
is the moment
well again I I was all for I was
thinking that LaVon would want to
actually press with white I was thinking
to play move like age five followed by
kingside expansion with f3 and g4 and
just maintain this knight on d4 but
there it is after Bishop f5 again I you
can't really stick anything on c5
because it takes twice in a row CA that
would be very unadvisable after Bishop
f5 yes it's not like you can stick the
whole c5 no we could take twice and play
like rook c8 I guess you could always
play Knight e3 we could also take right
away and then after rook c8 before
there's b6 exactly and yeah you don't
really want to get into this yes yes
regard of the white pieces just not
battling at all this it's pretty
frustrating if I'm a fan who showed up
to watch the greatest players in the
world play chess and it's a whole day of
it we were talking about I came here for
the day to come in and to see we haven't
played this kind of chess well Magnus
it's all I think it's about Magnus the
best player in the world like these guys
are taking a cue from him and they have
a draw not Fabi by the way you're
blaming Magnus I'm sorry I feel like a
baby magnets doing it in an absolutely
astonishing situation where even kramnik
and Gary were incredibly harsh then I
mean incredulous of the draw so maybe
they're saying hey if Magnus did it
because of this like cold calculation of
the math and why can't die I want to win
just like Magnus does I mean that's like
taking a cue from the number one player
in the world how can I argue there
because it's I'm with Maryse I'm sitting
there going man this isn't what I paid
to see yeah I want to see the two best
for the greatest chess minds the world
has to offer I want to see them mixing
it up and this is the marshmallows
marshmallows these are good buddies
about to watch some sports they're gonna
they're gonna it for the consolation
match this is what they're gonna do
tomorrow they can apply to rapid games
and the playing blitz for blitz and it
feels like this is rapid and then it's
all about whether LaVon can come back in
the woods this is a nightmare come on a
car you wanna three months ago everybody
on the planet was saying you're the
underdog why are you the underdog
Happy's not because of the match itself
it's because of the potential tiebreak
that's why you're the underdog
I'm Fabiana said I'm not afraid of that
scenario no Maurice and here we are
today we're back in the same scenario he
was in again it's London don't forget he
just had this problem in London right he
played for the title of his life and
because of rapid quicker time control he
had a completely disastrous Spanky I
mean didn't know there's no way to put
that three three zero that's never been
done in the history of tiebreaks
in the worst results ever and the worst
result possible even so he has already
had that nightmare he left London
virtually the next day he could came
back home to st. Louis to refresh he
goes back to London and what does he see
first thing he plays two classical games
against naka those ending draws and then
the disaster with rapid again well let's
hear his thoughts on this situation as
we do have him with Alejandro in London
thank you worries were here with Fabiano
Khurana you've drawn your game here in
the semi-final of the third place sorry
I guess Levon Aronian with the black
pieces obviously something that is quite
okay since you're a black but do you
feel that everybody's just targeting
you're wrapping a blitz not really I am
I don't love um probably wanted to get
more ideal opening than he got I mean
there's not much to talk about in the
game but whatever about the game a
little there is but it is dangerous with
like if I don't play Queen d6 and oh and
it can still be very complicated if I
play c5 SFC takes d5 in this position
yeah which is a double that should move
I mean you take some strategic risk with
white but you also get dark squares and
you try to attack on the King side
all right so c5 here in this position or
at least you used to game alive yeah I
mean it's definitely it's very very
complicated after this see d5 is is
probably about equal you say that you
don't feel that people are targeting are
you're repping a blitz but you come from
two kind of difficult mini matches and
rapid do you feel that there's something
you really need to improve or for LaVon
not to do the same tomorrow no of course
I have to improve my play um I mean that
goes without saying but yeah I mean I I
don't think I mean these are very
ambitious players all of them and they
when they have the white pieces they
want to to win and especially since
classical is so weighted in this event
six points is pretty much an
insurmountable weed so nobody is playing
for a draw here it's just that sometimes
you don't get so many chances with white
sometimes the the play kind of
dissipates well we'll definitely be
asking your opponent about what he
thought of his chances today and where
it went wrong of course black draw good
result for you and good luck tomorrow
Fabi thank you well we go back to the
studio and we'll have Levon Aronian here
soon with us thank you
um controversial statements being made
there by my family because we're we're
commentators were on the outside looking
in on the flame and to us it's extremely
obvious what the top players are playing
for it they want to drag him to
let's unwrap it I guess he's saying that
this this uh opening has a little bit of
poison and maybe okay Biden was taking
one gamble one little v Gamble's in 1896
he knew a lot right but I mean hard to
imagine Bobby not knowing that after
having clean magnets and having to
prepare all of those lines yeah sure
here's how the players face they're in
the universal rating system which is the
combination of classical rapid and
bullets numbers for and numbers 5 in the
world and I'm guessing family's number
four because of the tiebreaks
and we do have a hundred thank you and
here we are with Levon Aronian who has
informed me he has taken two full points
from Faviana caranas rating the one I'm
sure with the white pieces you wanted to
press where did it went wrong yeah I'm
usually not the guy to go for a short
draw with white thing but since it's a
match I thought to be practical
after all I have much higher rating in
rapid Aviano so it's mathematically it
should be not the best decision so so it
is clear that there people are targeting
because rapid and blitz and this kind of
matches no he's a very good reputable is
player but he has a low rating so I mean
it suggested maybe he doesn't feel that
comfortable compared to regular chess oh
yeah was this a strategy going into the
game or did you feel that you just let
the advantage go at some point no no I
honestly speaking I check this line but
I mainly pay attention to other also
very interesting lines from black but
this Quincy six I remember that there is
this line would see five but it's it's
very very complicated I think see five
twenty six minutes to three H five
something like this and it's it's a very
dial double-edged position because you
know he gets his Bishop and so I I
thought that
had I prepared this before the game had
I not looked at the otherwise I would go
for this but so it's a little bit
surprised about which variation of the
petrified shows no I mean this position
they're a police for this in those four
books oh yeah so 95 was the one that I
expected the list because I thought that
the animals are safer okay
so 95 for a little bit of a surprise you
decided well mathematically it makes
sense for you to go into rapid and blitz
and that's where you're headed tied up
tomorrow well I have you here a little
bit
perhaps your insights on what's going on
in the MV l versus Nakamura again we saw
that Nakamura took quite a bit of time
to play this move F takes G three Bishop
d5 and now we're in this kind of
complicated Berlin endgame which tends
to dissipate but before that happens
usually there's a lot of rings wrinkles
that are very important I think the most
important point is if black can
neutralize with f5 if I right away in
this position yeah because it looks the
most natural if I can make this work
man are oq5 this is maybe not so safe
Bishop g5 yeah here at Bishop g5
targeting the rook and their route d7
coming yeah maybe something like I don't
know so 995 rook at five takes takes
only six then it's slightly worse for
blocking maybe that can be unpleasant
right so all these guys tend to run away
yeah maybe he keeps the pressure right I
feel very convincing with some of these
preparations against the Berlin
obviously he managed to get a little bit
of something against you in the rapid
game so I just created trouble for
myself by being too ambitious and
somebody does that happen here after a
five then we think that perhaps white
retains the pressure with rookie Fife
any other candidate moves if you just
take the rook and then this should be
quite unpleasant
it should comes 25 I don't know
so perhaps a little bit of difficult to
hear free car Nakamura to fully equalize
in this variation despite it being you
know a Berlin endgame I mean it all
depends if he's in time to get this
piece is quickly like put one on b5 a
knight on d5 so but definitely there are
some questions to answer right well a
little bit of pressure then for the
Frenchman Thank You LaVon for joining us
here good luck tomorrow in the rapid and
blitz as we determine in the third and
fourth place of the grand chest or this
season it looks like it's a critical
moment here for Nakamura's these two
moves f5 and rook takes c6 that have
been discussed ER so dramatically
different in terms of the character of
the game and that results right well I
think rook takes a six is just the
ending that LaVon was pointing out rook
takes c6 rook takes c6 Bishop takes c7
it's quite clear that white is the only
one for choice this Bishop is actually
going to have this beautiful outpost on
the E Phi Square dominating both the
defense of c3 the attack on the poem g7
and then mmm this majority of two for
one can make itself clear whereas I
think that f5 is by far the more
difficult move for the white player to
to face down after rook ePHI that's
still some complicated stuff going on
here I can take on this pawn and see if
I can't deal with rook d7 by moving my
knight well let's just ask Maurice
Maurice what's going on and this is f5
the right move well if I is being given
as the best move for sure the ending
you're talking about will always be
slightly worse for black no question
about the one you're you dismiss
mistakes yeah etc but f5 is sharp by
itself we should point out this move
rookie five very strong because after
takes h4 is what the engine really
like Cyr and suddenly this rook is
finding itself in a very strange
situation note this work will go to d7
Bishop will go to g5 and if you're gonna
get hurt so this position is not good
but the engine does say after f5 rookie
5 that the best move is rook to d8 very
interesting idea of trading off this
rook so now you don't have the rook d7
idea and now he's back to wanting to
trade on the g4 square so you move your
king I don't know why h2 or not f2 but
you remove your king here takes and now
obviously takes you lose your pawn so
Bishop to g5 is the line it's giving
takes and this really fascinating
position it's giving triple zeros
although block just sacrificed sorry
white just sacrifice a pawn and it's
trying to count on this pin as being the
thing this rook is trapped after all
there's some kind of maneuver to try to
come up towards the scheme but it's
still giving triple zeros in this
position and tossing out c5 as the best
move this we got a look at me yeah we
hasn't really got to look at really
carefully because this line is gonna be
a hard one for Nakamura to deeply
understand he's gonna have to dig into
to see if he's indeed equal here looks
like all his pieces are tied down he's
pinned on this square maybe I'll get a
chance to move his King and then figure
out how to move his knight but it does
look very quick like this King is gonna
come off the board again giving all
zeroes in this position is the computer
of course it's calculating billions of
positions a minute that said I would
like to go back to lavon's statement and
even its latitude after this game he
made it very clear that he wanted his
draw meaning every every concept every
every statement he made to me suggested
that I'm better than this guy in rapid
and blitz the numbers speak for
themselves
why play for anything else if it's
almost as if if it weren't Fabi just
just replace him with like let's say car
yakun right or Wesley right then you
would see a whole different attitude
from these players there no no was waltz
into a situation where you get somebody
like car yakking or playing you want to
play him in blitz mmm-hmm you're not
gonna just run there you would see more
contentious games but it seems like just
this
big player the disparity between his
amazing excellence in classical chest
and his rapid and blitz which is pretty
good I mean by our standards amazingly
not not by their standards it's just
very obvious that you go for the
liquidation mmm I'm fortunate because so
what happens do you is I think the
hybrid format was classical and blitz
and rapid maybe it seems really exciting
and awesome because it's it's all with
the spirit of the universal rating
system in the ground chest but maybe it
needs to be done a little differently
yeah let's make this point maxime and
and naka yes they're up there match up
right now has been pretty contentious
that's true right yesterday could have
won the game say it was closed today
he's going for it like he's trying to
make a drop do you think it's only Fabi
because he's weaker actually make that
point does this make ya Aronian versus
VAR Sheila Grove that was exciting
are you gonna want that match right if
you did the right thing
were they playing for draws in those two
he's still all been draws though no
forget the result that draws are gonna
happen we're talking about the spirit oh
no for sure opposition for sure but the
point is if it's if it's just gonna be
these some significant cases where
they're more likely to play for a draw
and then you add to it the massive draw
margin that there already is in chess
it's not really what you want right no
but again again I just think you know
matchups matter players yeah if you put
you put Magnus in front of one of these
players it's not like it well
Magnus could steer it into a rapid and
listen he wants to but if he was playing
against Nakamura for example he's not
gonna be thinking well I'm just gonna
dominate the guy wrapping a bush let me
just make two quick draws especially
since yes so it's a good classical score
against not good so then you're gonna
see contentiousness if it was car yakin
why would he just want to go into rapid
enlist that sounds like a toss-up to go
against the NACA or of uh Sheila Grove
their players matter and I think the
disparity is very very clear that this
player
players can go for us like that would be
the right plan he's too good in
classical so you can go for draws and
all the it's unfortunate because all the
other games I mean you talk about LaVon
again special aground he could have won
that match basically in a classical
abortion he was he was after it was
after him both games right but if for
example Hikaru Nakamura before the match
had it in his mind oh I'm gonna make two
draws in the classical and drag him to
his doom in the Blitz Hikaru sang into
himself drag who fatty okay but you
still got to draw those two classical
games and the game that he was white
that was a really great game I mean
there was some really good kingside
checkmating attacks that Faby was you
know really trying to throw and he Carl
just by the skin of his teeth drew drew
that game with black well I think these
hybrid permits are a really good idea
maybe just needs to be tweaked a bit I
think like if you had a combination
every day like if you had the classical
time control a little bit shorter mm-hmm
so that for instance the max length was
four hours and you had like a classical
game and a rapid game in the same day or
a couple blitz games in the same day
just so that like you mix it up so
you're it's not so heavy with these six
points where is LaVon said like or was
it Bobby you said like losing a
classical game it's just too big too big
you're out of the matter right you know
so are we going toward the time when you
know I feel like 2018 is gonna be a
demarcation you're in chess in many ways
because players are because organizers
are realizing more and more that chess
is becoming a bit too perfect if you
will the players are playing so well
that if you keep having these elite
players play against each other their
preparation time and time again they get
used to each other
their preparation is fantastic yeah the
defensive skill is just simply amazing
you watch the way they can neutralize
advantages it's and then the adventures
are tiny a little something to play for
and then it's gone organizers are going
to start maybe thinking maybe we don't
want just the elite players to play
against each other yeah like only
something like mix feel like Tata Tata
Steel will have a mix feel yeah you're
gonna see victories there you're gonna
get excited again about classical chess
no look at all these wins right well
because you're not seeing the elite play
the elite only the other thing they
might start doing is what Norway chess
is doing which which is as dramatic as
it gets
you get one time control that's it I
believe it's two hours for the whole
game and then if that's a draw that
you're playing i'ma get in-game
immediately right I mean that's that's
as extreme as you're gonna get as far as
I'm concerned I think that's the middle
roads to make it more engaging and I
think organisers are gonna start looking
at those middle roads and seeing them
take a look at page from the OHS and
saying do we want that the old-school
classical six hours luxurious more mad
anymore where it's about perfect chess
and all we're gonna watch is as draw
after draw after draw and you know
smattering of wins and beautiful games
but not enough to keep the fans fully
engaged and by the way not the word did
play that good thing so well done
Nakamura using his time at the critical
moment finding the right move I
suggested buying the bone by the way and
then he played 95 it was like that very
strange variation how did it go with
this Maurice was mentioning that like
there was a an idea of even playing h4
and stuff but what we did see is after
rookie 5 the immediate 95 rook takes f5
yes sorry might have four ricca four
will do should you should we go into
this for work ending though why not well
because I've got my candidate pass pawn
is more serious than your
geordie so let's say go h4 is this
really about the majority here in this
position well I don't know seeing the
rooks fighting against those pawns and
white having a heck of a time defending
them for example let's try let's try to
look to just rook each recive okay I
want to just ignore me yeah I wanted to
put my giving you the chance to bring
your other work into the game ah here
you can know what the heck this is what
I want to do with my rook I want to know
I was trying to I was trying to play to
e3 unless you're just ready to play g5
anyway well g5 rook h8 I kind of got my
pawns of the board I need okay let's go
this is a bit sharper I thought I could
neutralize you a bit easier than this
but I understand what you're saying here
with the rook ending just the pure rook
ending that Bishop is awfully strong I
don't want to have generator on the
board
yeah after rook takes f5 rook takes c6
you know your Knights that that was what
liván was saying if you could if you've
got the timing to play b5 maybe your
knight is the right minor piece right
it's it's it's it's all a timing but
it's also against one with the bishop on
the board though okay so rook takes
Knight takes you think this is the main
line as as it would occur this position
here what did i do i think i went h4 i
could also potentially try to neutralize
this rook with something like king f2
but okay guys a 38 minute game in our
consolation match where the classical
and we've got one classical game
and might as well have been rapid break
yeah sure do have a little piece on some
members representing the st. Louis you
Chess Club youth board youngsters doing
quite a bit to help promote chess here
in the st. Louis area I'm with Sam and
Katherine's is a chin ski off the st.
Louis Chess Club a youth board who has
done some fabulous fundraising for the
club welcome to the show first of all
guys tell me about this initiative okay
so this is the st. Louis Chess Club
youth board and we are a fundraising
entity full made up of high school
students to raise money through
different fundraising events for the st.
Louis Chess Club youth boarder Katherine
why did you guys come up with this idea
oh we came up with this idea cuz we saw
a need to help serve the show's to help
serve the st. Louis chess club we Sam
and I both have worked with chests he's
been playing trust for a really long
time and I have started a club at new
york's and the st. louis chess club
actually help give some donations and
help me startup it so because of that I
feel wait I feel like I want to give
back and help give kids another
opportunity to participate in sport Rus
now I know it was a funny event it was
it a extreme paintball park in Mills
thought Illinois tell us about that I
must have been really fun so we were
running the event and the event
consisted of a haunted paintball ride so
people would get on this little trailer
truck with like mounted paintballs and
drive through a course and whenever like
a little zombie would pop up you would
get to shoot it and that was the main
appeal to it also there was a scary maze
that you would walk through and people
would jump out at you but uh whenever
you would bring up a flyer to that half
of the proceeds would go straight back
to the st. Louis Chess Club youth
Florida
Fantastico tell us what other activities
do you guys do well we all have
representatives of this
we have a little bit of a smaller group
right now because we're trying to work
out kinks as we're expanding it in the
next couple years but we have some
representatives for instance are Corrie
AZ representative is teaming up with a
chiropractor center in the local area
and any time you buy a membership at
that Center and the month of December
half of those proceeds go back to the
st. Louis chess club that's all why is
it that you want to raise money for the
chest I don't usually do a chess player
but you must be familiar with the clubs
initiative is here yeah so the Chess
Club itself has helped me out a lot
they've given me coaches and also with
me and another girl in my grade school
we started off a Chess Club and they
helped fund it and give a coach to it so
because of that we want to give back to
this to the organization and who wins
when the two of you play nice my
experience with just as a little bit
limited
then his definitely I've won trophies so
yeah I have not gotcha but thank you so
much for everything that you're doing
and good luck well thank you
[Music]
I'm gonna make my room gonna live my
dream
[Music]
and Brock
[Music]
we're gonna live my dream
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to our coverage
of the London chess classic as you see
there's four boards right up there today
as we also have the British knockout
going on but all eyes right now on this
battle between mexi's Masha Allah Grove
and Hikaru Nakamura the game that will
be the last classical game here in the
grand chest for finals and mint tea make
something of this as you play it out yet
even though Maxim's pawn structure is
uglier than he curves yes what really
matters is not how pretty you are
but what's inside your chance of making
a bad spot well exactly
well there's two things that's going on
here that I see his advantages for
vaccine long-term he actually has his
for all the nice candidate majority on
the kingside that is to say I see him
playing h4 h5 early quickly in order to
be able to get a passed pawn secondly
right now there is a little discomfort
in blacks position between his King and
most especially the look on 8/8 if black
needs to play either rook to d8 or King
e7 and get that roof going so I see
white is playing move for example like
h4 something that I actually we just
discussed with Maurice before we went on
break with the idea of putting the pawn
on h5 and bringing the King to f2 now
black has ideas of c5 and rook a6 as
mentioned also has ideas of king e7 and
just developing this rook and it's just
one of those things that I think more or
less the game is going to be decided the
next four or five moves if Maxine gets
to play h4 King up to h5 and black
doesn't do anything Maxine has very good
winning chances if if he Carl gets to
play c5 and rook d8 gets his rook to a6
very good drawing chances sorry if he
played h4 h5 and King f2 and
Blackwell is like has to do something
very very consequent oh very conscious
yeah okay to do in that situation and
this end game certainly it's the type
that has the imbalances of the pawn
structure and that at least we could
look at because if you fix the pawn
structure and then it's just equal but
that dynamic possibility you mentioned
c5 going after this pawn and notes it's
very important how you get this passed
pawn because if it's I think if it's
just a trade of pawns yes I'm curious in
your opinion if my King were to be
standing in front of your par let's say
an eight six opponent right and my rook
is allowed to roam free how do you each
act me from in front of this pawn like
just how do you do it if you if you were
to just create the passport by itself my
king by some trade were able to flip
over to this side and stand in front of
this pawn your King couldn't support the
pawn so you're Rick could later because
I could check you and chase your king
away your rook can support the barn
because then you can't eject my king
from in front of that pawn either right
so that means the past H pawn by itself
if I can blockade it will with my king
will be insufficient to win the game
that said if I have if I can't do that
and my rook has to be the one in front
of it that's a whole different ballgame
then I'm gonna get killed your King can
support the H pawn then your rook roams
free and I'm the one fighting for my
life
so that's very important like how you
get this extra pawn past how you make it
work so you got to not only get the pass
point you got to make sure that my king
is not blockading in otherwise that's
gonna be a draw so that's the challenge
also the other challenge you mentioned
counter play for black these are some
yummies they look like gummy bears just
waiting to be captured so unless you
have some dynamic possibilities which
seems to say you should keep both rooks
on the board no otherwise and maxime has
gone for this move rook f1 again keeping
the energy of his rooks King up to d7 a
check is possible with a bull rook to e7
ready on tap to
checked against that doesn't look like
you're gonna keep both rooks on but the
two against one
I think that's how you maneuver that is
going to be really important
well well - to what you're just sat
there Maurice is that after rook f1 oops
excuse me yeah not to move h4 7 so you
you were mentioning I'm trying to get it
as you were saying upon 2 H 6 but if the
black King was thinking sticking on h7
defending it's all very nice at the
moment that black king is not crossing
the F line boundary so yes exactly the
Maginot Line indeed so the the black
king is not getting to the h7 square so
again I'm maybe I'm wrong I have been
I've been thumping the table for h4 for
some time but I what I don't want to see
is I don't want to see black getting in
the move g5 and kind of injuring my my
majority but ok let's say h4 and I don't
know rook moves ok just something like I
don't know this so I'm trying not to get
a passive position with black what do
you think about this line of play chat
unless what you're trying to do here to
be active right but still life you gotta
you gotta calculate it all out yeah like
I don't know some weird yeah eight six
well I do want to do this I was trying
to get too connected past greedy
perhaps I should not have done this but
okay that that was just a fantasy line
but you can see how the contours of the
fight this is what I was really trying
to say a moment ago when I was bringing
up this you know like what I'm gonna do
in this ending and the next half dozen
moves what happened okay I'm just I'm
guess yeah I'm guessing he wants to play
h4 I don't think that white very allowed
to do all what you just said h4 blocking
to figure out how to compete in the
short term against his pressure on his
position well and it's clear by the way
as we were talking about finally getting
a classical win yeah it's clear that
Maxime is not playing for a draw he
started from the very beginning trying
to oh yeah and met and we no naka has
not been great in classical chest his
classical chest worried it's less
slipped is not said you slip over he was
he used to be top ten now he's number 16
in the world he's not even twenty seven
fifty I think he was top four or five at
the time he was over twenty eight years
no I think he was this high per second
once okay if he went from number two to
number 16 that's a big foot I remember
at that time
more was here at the Chess Club you just
moved to st. Louis and I know that the
club was really just watching it like a
hawk and I believe there's just like one
tornado number three check number two as
well and yeah right now indeed he's
number 16 in the world although he did
pick up a few points obviously with
those two draws against Bobby right and
we have to see in the move H four by the
way and you Maurice you were about to
suggest another line of play for he
carve because obviously if I can play h5
bringing my king up what was the other
thing that you wanted to be the issue is
with rook H aids that was just a
suggestion
and can he play King King Edgar just
just just to free himself from this
full-scale bind that you have them in on
that okay now if you gonna trade Brooks
alright now have the Maginot Line King
up so on a good day I want to go King g3
King h4 and more or less escort my pawn
my majority yeah at the moment this
Queen site majority for Black has stuck
it hasn't all right so it looks like SB
I could play g6 that would be really
cool so that I was able to play like g
6h takes g6 look g8 and like just win
back my pawn and maybe that would be
nice but unfortunately we're kept seven
could be annoying that's very annoying
no rogue f7 is not not that irritating
cuz of Kings g6 you mean
well don't know music's King easy yes
King Edgar six yes you have to take I'll
give you my seat I'll give you almost
all those guys almost but the main
problem is that stupid Jeep that's the
one that I'm I'm most concerned about
and so well I'm just a I mean to result
game there so you can't
g6 and that isn't any ideas like that
because if we can consolidate and you
know trade off some of these pawns is
such a buying you have here
well again I'm sitting here saying from
blacks point of view I'm looking for
active lay if you want to play g6 gen
you can actually just start with the
move g6
oh yeah and play for King e6 or rook g8
or what have you but there's no question
that he cars on the back foot and he's
done something earlier that got him into
trouble
please you know for some reason that it
was not possible to create a passed pawn
against White's pawns but is it is that
truth you mean b5 see 585 beat before
you can try it by all means please when
it's not doubled you can't create a pass
one by force when it's when the pause on
B - mm-hmm but I assume that was the
case here as well but it seems like you
can create a passport I don't see
exactly how when I play when I play b4
yes well listen this is show it so the
big okay the fans can see it as well so
let's do I can also start with d5 okay
even though it's the worst one it looks
like the worst happens okay if there's
like let's let's just make a couple of
King moves away right a five King moves
c5 a
alright now if you push I will go a four
and I can play c4 there though mmm-hmm I
can create if I ha that is a good point
so then you can't even though I need to
pass may not be the right thing but so
and if you capture with your a pawn
obviously I already have a passed pawn
if you have run beep on to say let's try
that thing with the C pawn then I can
take with it and again you you you've
undone from doubled and I can't and your
majority is working got a candidate
counterplay okay now back because I just
for some reason I
I had this because I'm gonna be wrong we
gotta look for work at 5:00 so there's
some tactical so try try be five again
five again okay I just want to make sure
though with the same and try no try see
for now try see for four black for white
oh but see for you can still just play
eight five and I can't
yeah I don't have time to stop your
passport from occurring i oh yeah of
course I do
I was gonna play C 5 and then C 3
alright but now I've stopped the past
pawn right right I mean okay you can
take yeah yeah so alright so that's it
factually you can stop a three against a
four against three but we should know
these are the kind of things just what I
know right you want to know as you go
into it and I had that as something I
knew but that there was no counter play
for black on that side what you wanted
to emphasize though maurice was that in
case that c3 pawn was on the B 2 square
oh god I knew that the four versus three
you can never get can never make a so if
we start with a five it doesn't really
matter they're still saying it's no c4
you can still play for so forth
I can play c4 jam and I can still play
c3 right and the three pawns are
neutralizing the four and if you don't
play c4 let's go back a couple if you
don't play c4 then a fourth automatic
then you automatically get b5 + c5 and
we get it so so I don't have time right
if black is given the time oops excuse
me to get a 5 B 5 + c5 then he can get
his majority will land well that's a
that's an interesting fact to note
because it's not the rook ending changes
things dramatically obviously because as
you're sacrificing pawns well I could've
just accept them and say yeah I'll take
one and I'm IRA gets a B file and I'll
use
but King important endings would be
critical because if I know you can't
create a passed pawn and I have the
technique immediately I go c4 c3 you're
frozen and now it's time for me to go
kill you my two to one on the other side
right or just use the two to one as a
distraction and then go run and gobble
up all your pawns on the other side
right so the so we know it's those are
the kind of things you always liked
those conceptions to put in your pocket
right you just automatically know that
for against this three I know how to
neutralize it automatically this is how
you do it and that's gonna allow me to
play a certain way of course once you're
adding pieces that changes as well but
the pure King and King upon ending is
where the knowledge we just said would
be the absolutely most useful now
conceptually another opportunity perhaps
of getting counter play it depends on
how white is doing his King side play so
you could play for b5 or Pietra be six
work a6 right and the the other play
that I was playing for was c5 which
keeps your majority alive
you could still be playing for B 5 and a
5 you don't lose anything with c5 and I
was playing for this lying of counter
play white white play is pretty
straightforward he's gonna go h5 King G
to King g3 and just keep going on the
King side by the way say about all of
this right it's for white after what
move for black we're it we're in this
position right age for right
only a slight edge for white and given
black as the line actually just
discussed look at that work up and King
to e8 allowing this national line we
talked about crossing of course the
famous Maginot Line in France the French
tried to use to separate themselves from
the Nazis didn't work out very well
historically but at any rate this is now
this point in white will play King to G
- right the engines giving rook to d8
right natural activity King to g3 and
essentially trying to get counter play
with this move
King h4 the rook f2 looks quite natural
as what would work if two rook d1 well
then I play that way if that's how you
want to play and now something like King
h4 and push this is not gonna be easy
the engine so only giving a slight edge
which is a crippling one it's remarkable
once you get your king to g5 into g6
really bar this bar should be up here it
looks like but somehow the engine feels
like it can still hold this position
kicking for c5 what are you hoping for
three playing six sorry yeah yeah c5
King G 5 D 6 D 6
you can't allow King G 6 you're just
resigned it and if I play rock H 1
engine still doesn't care okay P 6
okay they're just being stupid you can
play more like that okay f7 look like
yes you across the line now just manage
to cross the line although hold on we're
seeing an end game no no Rick g6 check
is as I'm sorry alright so how do we
also then how do we make progress here
that's why the engine thinks it's okay
stubborn engine yeah finding away giving
us everything and then still finding a
way to stop it when the time comes so
again it's the point we made about the
pair of rooks right remember I liked
having a couple of rooks on the board
once a pair of rooks come off then it's
harder for you to figure out how to get
what you need going and remember we we
mentioned by the way that this idea can
I make a pass pawn you can and I make a
pass pawn it's important because okay
you can play row g6 here so it's a bad
move but I want to just get to some
ending like this one right something
like like this okay well I guess I can't
play that move what else could I play b5
Yahweh be fine oh because I well and in
push a 5 and then a 5
[ __ ] age so I have to play King g8
right now right okay and now the fact
that I can make a passed pawn this is
the ending we were talking about the
fact that I can actually create the past
pawn it it whites in trouble
is that true was late wait a minute why
can you create the past primaries after
c4 just play as c4 you go c6 I get it
right yeah so now white is G's first
thing to come on this side because if
you play this move I can play here right
and you come over and now you got a four
not play here and whoops passed pawns on
its way right and we have to actually
figure out how to compete against this
this is what we wanted to know how to
compete against it King g8 no b5 excuse
me d5 in this position v v g5 King g8
and the c-4 move doesn't help because of
no because of c6 and now we're gonna
play for this this push etc so it's
actually quite easy to grade the
passport for black if you don't
initially placed for very quickly right
which puts us all the way back here here
rook d6 should we play see for now but
that's that's its own thing well I'm
trade off a pair of rooks how do you get
through yes yeah I liked everything that
we did for for white there we're right
here the longest time but I think black
has to play this move rook h8 h v king
e8 kind of business I wasn't even
actually sure that King e8 was forced I
I must say I was i h5 I actually thought
that c5 was more or less the way to go
with the rook
you know swinging its way across I
didn't understand why King e8 well
you're losing the timing with King
the reason I wanted to play this is
because I feel like now you can get your
up to d8 that wasn't the reason why the
reason why was I thought a second rook a
pair of rats helps wife okay I don't
know why I just that just was there in
my head but I felt like if you have
rooks on the board you want to get rid
of a pair of Brooks because it becomes
harder to support the pawns and to keep
the pressure going and to keep even
mating ideas and activity white once as
much activity as possible
if so you think it's in blacks favor to
get to get a pair of rooks off there
looks off but okay but I didn't know I
couldn't defend against these stupid
pawns until the engine showed they could
put a rook on d6 right that's
interesting because then you could get
your counter play another way you can
play for you come in for the same
character play with c5 etc if you're a
rook is on d6 so you're you're you're
forcing me to ask a question
should I not maintain the four rooks
right but now but now I can be active
myself so rookie 3 for example is very
direct rookie 3 is a very rookie 3 sorry
it's a very direct move I agree with
that is it a threat to capture I suppose
it is can I ask the question do you want
to give up the e-file and take a lot of
pawns I always think that if I can get
this one pawn this one g7 pawn and you
get all my anti pawns
see I don't like your books like those
stupid rooks are on the board yeah they
are working they're gonna work really
well together I'm thinking that you know
you could take my whole Queen side but
you should go to f4 because if you go to
H where I always have that g6 idea which
is kind of oh sorry a little bit of a
party-pooper King 8 for a g6 in this
case yeah I think you know you want to
pass
right for sure unless you can like try
to make me somehow that I I might yeah
where is it all right yeah and then that
Jeep on is actually really really really
dangerous well also because not only do
I have to Deepa Hans and not one which
is the nice little loaded gun but on top
of that I can also use the Jeep on as a
shield for my king mmm-hmm right when I
go to my g5 it uses well also yeah in
that line your rook your rooks doubles
on the seventh right yeah right
that's the kind of thing I'm trying to
not waited all the laws so when the rook
went back to f5 right keeping rooks was
a really important point now I have to
figure out how to deal with maybe rook
III was a bad move let's try a rookie
for yeah that was what I was more fear
fearful of it was rookie for maybe sorry
sorry Maurice maybe I just start like
this
rook here if you play rook e3 isn't it
isn't it actually just kind of a
transposition which is maybe not what
your and I think that's actually a great
sign he's sensing the critical moment
well this a sign for who and I think
he's going to save it but he knows the
moments on f5 he also went into a ten
minute thing yeah Oh with without
question yes mighty sentence is very
alert here okay so like the problem as I
see it is if you let wide achieve g4 and
h5 there's this really really big
problem that the king may come in and if
I would in black shoes I would really be
analyzing rook h8 and c5 as well as
Jesus
to my mind this moved g6 is like the
crucial alternative rotates on the board
immediately
by the way when when when he kuru
there's this long think wrong think idea
but that's not always the case he crows
a pretty notable mistake yesterday was a
four he played I move in just over a
minute yeah in this green felt ending
after a for maximum all these great
possibilities right with Bishop c4
threatening Bishop e3 exactly that moves
pretty quickly and that was that rookie
to stuff yeah yes yes but let's go let's
go to that position at age five what do
we got King e8 right yes okay look okay
we tried a lot of bushes you played rook
at Ford I did okay one one rook move we
didn't try was rookie to rook e1 I
played those rook moves you just calmly
brought your cane into the game right
but what if we don't allow your king in
you can't play g5 if you play rook back
to have something with any I'll practice
on g5 rook takes h5 basic oopsy-daisy
yes like something you don't want to do
although you know you know that's not
gonna work he's on the seventh against
rook f7 rookie seven just repeats yes so
that's nothing extra special hmm
do I gain a temple Maurice by offering a
rook trade in this way or this King and
pawn endgame started to look at that
King and pawn anything again
yeah is it and we he's played King e8 by
the way as Hikaru so he's heading
straight into our main line using
understanding he's definitely studied
this and
and this is where again I was I've been
playing rook every single line so one
more look so you're saying after I drop
my rook back we should have been
concentrating on rookie two to stop the
king okay so how would it go Maurice
have to look up to looks like you have
the trade okay and okay
you brought my king one step closer Qing
Yi seven rook h6 now here I'm assuming
you don't want to get into it straight
king upon ending like this is this is
the problem here is I see it is
I'll use my h6 pawn as a distraction
while I'm getting my king all the way to
the Queen side this is so lost I don't
write and why the engine that's not just
giving it doesn't see beyond it this
horizon right
it's the horizon problem yes it's just
it's it's so lost
yeah it's completely okay so I'm
assuming that's really lost
all right so kiza yeah king e7 is it's
fine King here creative rooks instantly
by the way by whoa no finesse Hey video
just says the position I don't need any
as you say finesse I'm just gonna get my
king up the board and I'm gonna go for
King g3 King age for it and do you know
how to defend against that well the way
we defended last time was we put our
road for d8 and rook the d6 I not sure I
understand why you're not playing rook
h6 and c5 by the way why do we need to
play with d8 I think you get immediate
counter play against the pawns
well I don't want to play the same
position it's isn't it the same speed
because your rooks not going after the
if you play a 65 you're not really going
after my ape on a baby that's what
you're after right why not
rook King foolish King King so I could
have my rook on d6 or I could have my
pawn on c5 and b5 or okay let's let's go
let's just have a look King right
correct what else
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa Jesus yeah this
is where you're right Jen this is where
you we had tried rook g8 rook f7 and we
weren't too excited I didn't like the
fact that he kept that second G pawn on
the board
I didn't mind losing the pawns on the
Queen side because I feel like the king
the the white pawn structure is so
compromised they're gonna you're gonna
get chances right my problem is that
stupid Jeep on right right back that one
in the back this guy this guy is real
and a real distraction but King in front
so now you know what what line is is he
car calculating well I think I know it's
okay so what's going on so takes Ruby
rook well there's rook f8 also but okay
rook g8 you so now after work out seven
checking ethics I think but king g6 is
another possibility when you were afraid
of g7 right right that's true so King
any sixes what we were looking at
preventing g7 with the idea that after
Rick c7 takes takes change tags and now
I want to hold the guy and now I want to
do something here right so okay r g5
right
rook takes no stop because you've got
two interesting choices okay five rook a
five now here we go
if my King gets in front of the pond
remote we were arguing about getting it
right if your King was on 86 or h6
yes you're not cutting me off if my King
gets in front of the pawn how do you eat
ject to me from in front of this pawn
and if you're not winning the pawns on
the Queen side how do you win the game
and if you play rook d7 here because you
got this okay but wait let lets let's
hunt this one down for a second well if
you want if you go king over just me did
you get now 37 that's what I mean that's
where that makes a little bit more safe
so maybe we can just go for the pawns
after King age 4 because that's what I
was thinking
you start with a three let's say and we
do have these 56 by the way hey rook e8
of course okay but this is looking very
close to a drop very close to it wrong
yeah it is I will look for a pond at for
one pond and then it's an easy drop okay
very good so what is this was what
knocking was tanking about he was
calculating this long working day mind
making sure he was okay and to me it's
curious that he thinks so long a couple
moves before but then when he gets
closer to the position for most people
that your vision is clear hmm but for
knock I don't think it didn't matter he
did the work before this is one of the
things that I think these great
calculators Hikaru Nakamura Fabiana
Magnus Vichy they they just see you know
a great variation
many many moves deep and I bet you we're
right that Hikaru has calculated right
up to this point and beyond and he
thought that he could be forcing the
draw you know with some variation there
he is seven check King e6 allowing the
decimation of his Queen side or maybe a
couple of pawns on that side at least
but understanding the critical point is
to not be cut off from the Jeep on with
his King King could cross that line the
F line yes that F line yep then he will
be able to defend the Jeep on quite
easily and meantime his active rook will
look for counter play on the other side
of the board and as long as you cannot
create any kind of distraction on the
Queen side by white then what how can
white win he cannot make it happen the
rook and King will defend very nicely
it's remarkable because the white
structure on the Queen side was busted
up by Bishop takes efficiency for takes
c3 almost from the opening the
repercussions felt all the way to this
endgame and if that be - Palmer was on
b2 and not c3 I think after rook takes
c7 it'd be a window [ __ ] crying yeah
it'd be a win at one position that
double that double pawn so we're looking
at rook take c7 rook takes g7 has
occurred has occurred King g3 chemo for
up g5 rook takes rook a5 now it's it's
not a nice way of treating the rook
[Laughter]
[Music]
exactly the would go to a for the king
would go to f6 and then what is the rook
doing on b3 that's very very passive
rook massively done by the car oh yes we
understand this and just realize he had
to get his play even at the
cost of a pawn the queenside clear what
mister to pump and in this case again
yeah because of a second pawn so its
side is so busted up but more critically
getting the King in front of the pawn
right was the primary focus number one
yes that fact once he's able to do that
it's too much work trying to push him G
pawn forward that that is welcome
proceeded impress all calculated
definitely definitely very impressive
and we were we've been talking about the
extraordinary defensive position that I
mean these guys there's no question he
carros worse but he sees this way of
drawing the game by going through this
very very long calculation and he says I
can draw that rook ending and he
immediately goes for it by the way it
again you know there's some
understanding that goes on so I had a
feel for this position in terms of I
wanted a rook a pair of rooks off the
board it's great right that I knew
having two rooks felt very annoying and
looked like it was more pressure I
wanted to get my King in front of that
pawn you're gonna get a passed pawn
eventually right yeah that's that's
general understanding for you you get a
you know enough right but to calculate
it from this from step one not just you
know this is what I wasn't but no go all
the way and say oh and this and this and
this when we get to this moment when
your take on b7 and you try rook c7 I
have this that's where the separation is
yeah the deep deep calculating ability
that takes it 10 12 15 moves deep say
yeah we know what you generally want but
how do you execute it in a forcing way
and it's something about Hikaru we
mention all the time when he defends he
looks at positions as problems to be
solved he doesn't want to just sit there
he wants to find a concrete path
to prove the truth of the position and
he looked and found the four signal of
g6 and he didn't hesitate from playing
the move he didn't get fearful of the
fact that he's about to give the guy a
clear pass G pawn
remember we said whoa past Jeep on
Brooklyn the seventh wait a minute rooks
going hog-wild do you really want to go
there
Hikaru went straight there and found a
clean draw at the very end that's some
really impressive stuff
yeah just bringing up this position I
think in 2050 in the children's
scholastic school books they're going to
use this example and it will be like e
six black Black's worse but show the
forcing variations wrong the first thing
and at five so the first thing you say
is the minor piece favors white so you
get rid of the minor piece then you get
into this four rook ending and you
sacrifice to pause forced the Rope get a
pair of rooks off sacrifice the pond you
need to see five play after King G three
exactly and find the good move here
rook g5 and then this will be this is an
instructive endgame for sure this will
be in in books yes will be in books
deservedly but the children's scholastic
school book right now for the 23rd
century yeah like this will be one of
our prime examples 36 from Fabiano's all
right that will be very easy that would
be chapter I want to do is involve that
rapidly but by then just will be boring
to those I don't know played on a once
way
you know with all those squares and
extra pieces Hawkes will have to land on
the board
Star Trek v dimensionals that's a hole
that's nice this game has been solved
and Wow that said the way these guys are
playing they're making this chess board
of ours look smaller yeah they're making
it look like we know you thought I was
in trouble but who would argue was
rushed Sheila Graff going for the win
today
of course yeah yeah was he giving it at
all yes did he have a significant was it
significant enough no was naka just
gonna fold no other we might have had
let's say Lasker Stein it's Lasker might
have played this ending out masterpiece
look at the two against one on the
kingside the way he did against then
it's back in the 1800s and we all went
Bravo this is how you win in the
reuleaux PES you get your majority and
your milk and you and you win not
today's guys today guys like know we've
seen all of that we know what's coming
now we know how to put up resistance
exactly that is chess in the 21st
century that differs now from the days
of old exactly yeah and these players
are obviously standing on the shoulders
of these giants who have taught them all
of these things and they've taken their
lessons to heart Jennifer they really
this is this is really really impressive
stuff again the purists and us can
applaud and go wow I mean these guys are
really really good and yet we want to
see blood too though I mean we need
victories this is so artistic this is so
beautiful the defense was so magnificent
you might as well start writing books on
defense
the art of defense right and it's called
the art very few very few books on the
art of the face most of the books you
see are puzzles on made into even right
you don't see puzzle rush giving ho the
great defensive idea
right now right it's all about that mate
baby it's all about made in school it's
all about winning yeah we we thrive on
that and so to get excited about defense
it's not easy it's it's clear that he
played masterfully beautiful artistic
wonderful how many of us are still gonna
be like whoa boy needs a rebrand I reran
be all the tactic one of the old tactics
because I had had a chapter on pursuit
that was like all about you know
pursuits finding sneaky stalemates and
perpetual oh yeah I think that that
could use a rebrand pursuits not a good
word right something better but yeah I
mean you know like I'm a beginning I
thought football fan and yeah defense
wins championships and stuff like that
but you're right I mean we have been
schooled on the many techniques and
stuff like that we're not been really
schooled on how to say but to puns down
in a classical game see it got a wee for
sacrifice now upon second followed by a
piece sack followed by another piece we
got out of our Queens and followed by
mating with a pawn you're one of those
the elevation of attack so can you get
to that level where your sacrifices are
so mystifying that the guy doesn't spot
it weeks in advance and then prepare
some exchanges where he gives you a pawn
and get your rook upon anything which he
knows how to draw now that Women's
Championship while we were watching the
London World Championship match and
seeing that knockout event that the
ladies brought there was energy boy that
was fun
I must win Game four with the black
pieces Wow okay sorry we're gonna take a
quick break oh yeah
learn more about our sponsors here at
the London chess classic and
Grantchester at this time the lohia
foundation
[Music]
I think many people don't know that
cataract blindness Indonesia is number
two highest in the world this is no
longer a health problem but a social
problem
[Music]
whether your king or your beggar you
deserve equal quality items
it all started because of dr. Ruth who
runs the taganga IRA care hospital in
Nepal and I read about him I was
following his story and I was extremely
fortunate to meet him in Singapore I
think that's where our journey began how
many fingers am i holding up do not do
what I see inspired us to consider
looking at cataract as one of the
healthcare initiatives for our
foundation
[Music]
I often say we are changing lives
because all these people who come walk
into our camp who are blind and leave
the next day with high side I have
personally heard so many stories from
each camp where truly lives are changed
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how do you feel very happy I mean I'm
very happy now my eyes all playoffs
oh very nice
[Music]
I'm so happy to say that in this
cataract camp they were more than 15
volunteers who flew in from different
parts of the world just by word of mouth
we were able to inspire even 13 people
[Music]
restoring eyesight is such such an
immediate effect they come back the next
day and they're able to see
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is class changing experience you
see a person blind one today and
tomorrow
the person can see you again I mean how
what more can you ask for what what are
the miracle could be reversible
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
United States the st. Louis chess campus
in the heart of the vibrant Central West
End has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess and is
comprised of two unique nonprofit
institutions the Chess Club and
scholastic Center of st. Louis is
recognized as the top chess facility in
the world and plays host to all major
tournaments including the u.s. Chess
Championships and a Sinquefield Cup one
of the strongest chess tournaments
globally tournaments are broadcast
online to more than 150 countries led by
an expert commentary team of
grandmasters the Chess Club is an
educational organization committed to
promoting the game of chess with a
specific focus on bringing the benefits
of chess to children throughout the st.
Louis area research shows children who
play chess exhibit improved analytical
skills and increased confidence the
Chess Club is highly engaged with the
local community bringing scholastic
chess programs to more than 100 schools
providing hundreds of classes each week
directly across the street from the
Chess Club is the world chess Hall of
Fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the US and world chess halls
of faith cutting-edge exhibitions
feature rare historic chess artifacts
paired with world-class art innovative
programming explores the intersection of
chess art and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions and monthly music in the
galleries the world chess Hall of Fame
is nothing you expect and everything you
love three different galleries and a
premier gift shop highlight the culture
history and creativity behind the game
come visit play chess leave enriched to
learn more about the st. Louis chess
campus visit STL chess campus org
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we are back for our coverage of the
grand test or finals at the London chest
classic and of course we have this one
game under way between paradox amour and
NVL Louis where we've been seeing
Nakamura play this really precise
defense and I think that grandmaster
Alejandra Ramirez in London also wants
to weigh in on this
all right that's hello my 100 what's
happening well thank you yeah so you
were here live from the Olympia Center
it's of course been a day about just one
game the other one ending in such a
quick draw perhaps a little bit about
the format we've seen that people like
to make that draw just before the
quicker time controls they don't want to
expend the energy and Levon Aronian
he said it very clearly mathematically
he's the favorite in rapid and blitz he
wants to take his chances there I do
have a question about the other position
though guys I don't have a engine strong
enough to really answer for me and I
haven't been able to really discuss it
with anyone else around in this position
Maxime played rook f7 almost like if it
was the only move in the position played
very very quickly but I still haven't
been able to figure out why not play
some combination of King g3 work at five
or the director at five takes and King
g3 and the simple idea is to push the
pawn to g5 that destroys your idea of
the defense with the rook being under
the pawn if you play King e6 I had
thought simply King f4 was extremely
dangerous this rook is just basically
trapped and if you play rook d6 a g5 I
wasn't really sure how to draw this
position because the engine was to play
Ruby 2 for a while but then realizes the
rook if - it's a lost pawn in game so I
didn't really figure it out perhaps you
guys over the studio with a stronger
engine and more analysts can tell me
you're a little bit more about the truth
of the positions well thank you for the
question Alejandro I was about to say
dude you're you you were just at Google
headquarters give alpha0
quick call and just check on it I think
we had some ideas of c5 and rook a six
maybe something similar to game
what about that move rook f5 you know
it's a very good point I'm glad
Alejandro brought it up because I had
seen it and seen the engine suggests the
move Alejandro and then he so quickly
went into the rook have a line that I
just
apologies forgot to mention that this
was another possibility and a way to
avoid that forcing endgame line where
white is ahead and the injured fields
has a real significant more significant
edge than he does in this position point
seven seven that's a lot by our book now
the engine also saying that you can't
get in your move see five yards so
obviously there's a quick capture on the
c5 squared
maybe this is how he's gonna have to
defend but here the engines give white I
realize we have to really dip into this
position to see whether or not it's a
winning edge how would you proceed in
this position if you're gonna try to
execute you can't play c5 and get your
rook over without giving up the c7
pollen I don't think you want to do that
in this position mm-hmm so it is a
challenging line this way of playing is
different and the rook d6 might be the
only defense now right same idea going
in this direction allowing this move g5
on the board and you can weigh in
whenever whenever you want house maybe
in rook d1 rook d1y a g6 I got rook
Jiwon checks course so we're gonna go up
the board so it's something similar to
the game but I'm a vastly improved
version maybe route d2 now yeah last
time I was afraid of rook a little bit a
problem but is right but even here the
engines giving well jeez six and we see
two you have to be very watchful because
whoa look at seven it's giving King e6
and now whoa this looks very very
similar to our position or a game design
so that doesn't look like it's getting
anywhere
how do you win any doing back here well
Andrew I think that this is better
a much better winning attempt once we
saw what what he Cara did with rook g5
there's nobody that's like what do you
call it the 20/20 hindsight there's no
moral victory or something yeah I was a
piece up when we agreed to a draw it was
Ryan Knight versus King you got so lucky
yeah however it works out so right there
are some victors there's defense it's
not easy to break through with the
limited material that was was it what he
has right now in the game who's this
it's exciting to see your point on g6
but isn't it it's this rook if it can
decimate this well if you can capture
this pawn get over on this side sooner
or later he'll be able to capture this
pawn if he can't bother you enough with
checks bring his king this way and that
his his pawn be the major distraction
you're not winning this position
captures captures an a3 has been cleaned
it takes a three and black is ready to
give away his rook for the Jeep on and
then use his King to escort his C pawn
up the board now let's take a look can
we do it how would it go James go g7 and
now we can start with a chatter I'll
start with a Jack I think that's a very
important effect check
draw it once yeah it looks like that
because the I mean you've got to win no
you can't win the rook by playing Brooke
rookie 7 check by the way takes pieces
makes more sense for the moment but just
going down the line sorry the pawn is on
g6 yes so you just played rook takes a
three and now work takes me 7 ok well
now I'll get in there oops excuse me
I'll get in a mouth slip let me get into
check like a king e8 let me watch this
forest pretty much pushes forest and
let's go with this guy and this is where
you can see the ending well let's take
on a sudden first yeah and I will I will
go escort my well you didn't I tried to
resistance play c4 instead justice rose
well no I oh I remember of horrifying
game from dad we're on zoton ski she
pushed upon without escorting it with
her King and then her King got cut off
like for instance if the King were
already on f-89 then Dani of like rook
a5 would cut the king so I would I mean
my instinct is to just play King d5
understood but let's play c4 just on
okay see because this as far as White's
concerned
white has no way of promoting this pawn
period without really there's only
there's right so let's this is the
technique I want to show so now but even
here a chatter threat you can block so
now tonight's forest yes precisely
takes this forest and now you're good
easy draw easy drummers oh yeah oh yeah
okay so okay hold on let me just refresh
so I can just get the exact game
position and we are here
rook takes p7 was the last move so where
are we are expecting a check came to e8
and then Rupp to g3 and then it's all
about pushing this passed pawn rook
check okay rook check yeah rook f7 rook
FC has checked by the way I work after
reject play if I felt by it GE GES
played rook f7 sorry and now rook Oh
rook to b3 yeah so he's threatening rook
check enforcing the King to step in
front of the wife white to move and help
made in one I sensed where you're going
yeah this is more pretty much prettier
nice oh yeah that's an auto update sorry
that that is not that's not the game
physician he played he played rook back
to c7 or he took upon rook to see
something seven okay this is a smile
joke because the game is totally drawn
now we can check King and yeah we
wouldn't know I'm a dc-3 and rook c7 was
playing oh okay this is the current
and I was yeah I mean obviously white is
all about trying to promote a spawn so I
was thinking okay let's force White's
King to step in front of the pond so I
can gain some time by the way the way
hikaru played it's just one of various
ways to draw this position really
because he could have also did Jackie he
could have also just sacrificed his rook
it's not yeah I mean he's way in time
way in time but at the moment he's now
making it difficult for white to push
this pawn so he played check King g7
right and King d5 exactly
and now Maxime looking for something to
do is now taking the eight-ball and that
is just accepting a draw survive we
rolled out yeah pushing this pawn that
this position is easily drawn you're not
tricking him okay sacrificing his rook
at any moment I'm gonna say that the
players are gonna play to King versus
King yep why not that way they don't
have to come up with some repetition you
know right and after c4 g3 yeah here
here Queen something of this nature is
what we are about to see
good prediction yes will you get it
exact no I suspect here I've made a
mistake I suspect that will would see
this I remember I was it was during the
deep blue matches and I asked Gary
Kasparov why did the computer promote
his pawn to a rock and not a queen and
Gary says well from the computers point
of view when you promote the pawns of
the Queen and you allow rook takes Queen
whose material so you promote it and I
just oh they actually reach the exact
position draw to the death or knock it
out okay again not the result we wanted
to but simply you know hats off sterling
defense goes to show that those
calculating skills are not just for
bullet chess and puzzle rug they're also
for saving the day top endgame and there
we have it two drawers from each side in
the classical portions we now move to
the rapid and blitz tomorrow to decide
who will be champion of the ban chest or
2018 I'm gonna be so excited
rapid blitz right this format we see in
front of us here that's going to be so
much ok question for our panel
where will the victory where will the
Grantchester winner come from what will
be from the rapids or the blitz portion
you're gonna need the Blitz game blitz
at some point you're gonna have to you
cannot slip up in the blitz but four
points is a big
the semifinals exactly first of all you
got to get the four points yeah you have
to win one and draw one doubt you're
gonna win - yeah right one and drugs we
want to draw one so that's what starters
right and second of all you can't slip
up in the Blitz and I think that when
you can slip up one but you can't
support so one little hiccup but two
games guys back in business that's four
games to catch up so I think that the
differential was more severe in the
other time control where you did you
were talking about new numbers one and
three in the world
yeah right they were clearly better than
their opponents right clearly better if
you had to make a bet you bet maxime you
bet hikaru and you collect your money
you know that's was a given but now do
you want to bet like who do you want to
bet for in this setup
maxime versus the card this is not an
easy bet guys in the UK knockout
championship it was with Luke McShane
and Micky Adams I believe Micky Adams
lost both rapid games he was down by 8
points and in the Blitz he won the first
three blitz games so he's only 2 points
behind then Luke McShane won the final
blitz game to win the match and get to
the finals in the UK knockout an extreme
case but it would be it I mean let's
face it it would be great to see the
grand chessboard decided in the blitz
where MDL is the number one rated player
in the world but I want a better knock
up and came forward finishes it off well
I think we're guy yeah I think go for an
interview or two your thoughts Jen you
didn't get in there on how you see
tomorrow playing out oh yeah I think
it's extremely close really a pick on
between Maxine
naca if naka it goes one one and the
rapid anything can happen I guess maybe
Mex me was a slight favorite on paper
yeah yeah which reading and then also
the rapid but not has been in great a
great form hasn't he III thought that in
the Blitz on the grand chest tour I
wasn't
hikaru better in the rapid but worse in
the Blitz I did I think that's right I
think Maxine you had the edge in the
Blitz and knock I have like a 2-1 in the
rapids something like that okay in the
Blitz one and a half four and a half in
the Blitz moves 1:1 matchups matter but
I would also like to see if we can bring
up these graphics has my Sheila grabbed
ever finished ahead or did he finish
ahead in any single event we know the
answer is no for Paris we know the
answer is no for st. Louis rapid a blitz
because knocking on both of those mmm
but what about livid did rush Selig Rob
they they finished third fourth and
fifth where was not going that Wesley
soul if we could put his like Wesley was
the winner Wesley was clearly the winner
I don't even remember who number two was
it was Ray Allen
yeah yeah yeah can was number two Sergey
yes but now we go here we go it was
there it is by sheila Grob did it finish
I Nakamura in one of the rapid and blitz
combination hybrid rapid blitz correct
events although knock up and knock a one
Paris and I think that Russia Legrand
finished just second to him and in her
in st. Louis no am I wrong about that I
feel like it was the case if we can get
that graphic I think he came in second
or was it Levon who came in second well
let's get there it is he did come in
second he came yeah that clear second so
look at them following each other very
very closely and we have the king of
Paris and st. Louis wrapping in blitz
going into the finals it is a Hikaru
Nakamura with
Thank You Maurice here we are with acara
Nakamura no classical games were
decisive here in London you earned a
little bit of pressure but it seems like
you held your own today yeah
maxime surprising with this g4 line I
mean I had looked at this before this 94
if she's actually 94 it was a surprise
and it was very hard because the round
here or there were so many moves I
wasn't sure if Bishop g5 was right or 97
was right he's that one immediately here
yeah I mean 97 h4 and then I don't know
like 95 or Bishop d5 I mean Bishop g5
and right I saw this I mean I thought
something like this should be okay but
it's it's very hard to play over the
board when you're not sure something
like h5 and the 93 93 is just complete
yeah anyway yeah I mean I saw this idea
but I wasn't sure about it and then I
then I played Bishop d5 um and I just
miscalculated this whole line after g4
Bishop b4 rookie for like 97 East six
five yeah I mean I miscalculated that
after rookie five I could not take on g4
yeah because is it a g5 I think it's h4
right away right and I mean I'm just I
should just be in trouble here probably
yeah but even here I didn't realize just
how dangerous this really was because I
thought I mean I should just be
completely fine but then once Maxine
played rukka five I took I also wasn't
sure if I should take on e6 as well I'm
like instead of night of for Rookie six
maybe yeah I wasn't sure like Bishop g3
b5 I mean like rookie five or something
like or h4 I mean I wasn't sure about
these positions like trade g 6h for
something like this I mean it's probably
okay but he can you can always put the
push bunt d4 and go like rook off one
and maybe h5 it seems like no matter
which position you choose you're under a
little bit of pressure yeah I mean this
objectively I think this is probably
better because I'm the one that I went
for I end up in trouble I think
well not trouble but like I have to be
super precise ER I just lose base
so work f1 King be seven yeah and I mean
yeah after h4 I started worrying because
originally I wanted to play rock h8 age
5 and g6 immediately but it doesn't
quite work yeah yeah because takes rook
g8 and I think it's rook you won first
right
can you ain't broke up six oh I can just
go rookie five or something okay anyway
yeah but I mean I saw something like
this and like I saw there's rook d4 and
I didn't quite see how he's getting the
pawn back so wasn't sure so I played
King e8
I mean I thought this was very creative
what I did take States can do - in g6
and yeah so he reaches its work g8 and
here Maxime went wrong with rook f7 I
mean okay where Cup sevens completely
fine but he sort of gives away all the
winning chances right whereas rook f5 I
think is a better try but still after
work g6 King j-3 I think II six I
thought was completely fine yeah I'm
like rookie two or something I know then
there's Ricky five wait wait I have to
be careful here yeah okay rook d6 rookie
six that's a good point yeah no actually
I should go Brooke these six because I'd
let him get his King one square closer
so g5 I'm like rook t2 and I mean I woke
up - okay me yeah maybe this is so bad
but but even here after rook e1 I'm not
sure it's losing right by something very
similar to the game when there's like
King G for work g1 King H v work g3 and
I'm gonna get some ponds before here
like this five probably checking g6 work
h3 and then you start grabbing some
pawns here if you might say I mean it's
a better version than he gets in the
game but I'm still not sure if it's it's
winning because he's gonna have to check
me at some point then I'm gonna run
right - like c5 so I think it's probably
still hold of why I felt like this
should be should be close to close to a
draw but I figure this this was my best
chance it's an excellent resource
Maurice was definitely pricing it using
the engine and it seemed that it just
kind of held together right yeah I mean
I was I was lucky because maxing played
broke up seven and then it's I mean
pretty routine and there
I don't really have any difficulties
whereas workout five I still have to
show some technique so yeah I was a good
good a good couple of moves there that I
found after after kind of miss playing
the middle game well definitely a good
effort you're going tomorrow in the
rapid and blitz so you consider yourself
a favorite well I mean I think maxing
would agree that I tend to play better
than him when we play online over the
board lately he's been a little bit
better so I think it's a bit of a
toss-up I I don't think you can really
give the advantage to either player
unlike unlike say my match against fob
beyond or even the match between foggy
on on the lawn tomorrow are you think
that live on is just heavily favored
against piano tomorrow yeah Livan she
all right results recently kind of
indicate that way
although for himself was saying that he
has been in some strong players perhaps
not in the last couple months yeah
obviously and the st. Louis match like
three years ago I think it was but no I
just mean I feel like LaVon is a little
bit more stable I feel like Fabiano and
and Blitzen rapid he can play while at
times but he's not generally playing
well and in every event it seems like he
plays well replays badly there's kind of
no one between where's the lawn I think
is just a little bit more stable
well Thank You Cara for joining us here
tomorrow you fight for what would be
your first grand chester title so good
luck to you should be fine alright and
we will see my see my Telegraph here
with us in just a second Thank You
alejandro fantastic judgment there by he
karo in understanding the rook and pawn
endings and the difficulties he was
facing I think he really had a good
grasp of what was going on Jen well he
said it was a pick'em in his match and
he just saw
Levon is more consistent yeah right it's
actually is true for sure sure but you
know doesn't mean when you say you
should win doesn't mean you will win
exactly very big difference in world but
that's why you play the game right we
saw it in the numbers consistent signs
in terms of LaVon this whole year while
Fabi is either in 9th place or he's up
in the top half right and he's had great
results he'd be grist trip for example
last year here Wow
which was a tremendous result but it is
true it's very odd the way Bobby seems
to either be spectacular
or just flame out late badly instead of
just always doing the right thing well
we'll see if he can do it tomorrow let's
go to London and MBL is with Holly
hundra
thank you guys let's see a hard-fought
draw you definitely went for it with
your preparation in the Berlin tell us a
little bit about what you expected from
the opening ones opening went just as
well as I could expect because eco one
dip into my preparation and of course my
position was very promising and then I'm
pretty disappointed at myself because I
did what heaven did against me again - I
played just too fast and missed mister
resource I mean like hook G to check it
was Ian's I mean it's my toe of course I
mean no g20 h2o yeah but of course it's
I mean I just played too fast and that's
not something I should have done well
it's good for tomorrow maybe for you but
yeah it's very possible that there was
no win anyway I mean that would maybe
some skill but it's nice for what I've
done
now you think to be one of the few
people that keeps finding resources and
keeps putting a lot of pressure in the
Berlin and game London oh this kind of
shine away from actually you know
because the ACA was bloody smoke so I
mean I got to give the credit to bloody
on this one not only invented the what
they'd invented
put it at a prominent stage and
apparently also creating problems for
black himself yeah you go tomorrow wrap
it on blitz you mentioned earlier that
you had a basque or gassy car along
online but how do you feel your chances
are all over the board I mean I think
they're pretty good but you know I think
eCos chances are also pretty good so it
will be like set at us that's all right
well what can we expect tomorrow do you
think there will be a huge amount of
reporters in preparation in the rapid
games or do you think people are gonna
just try to rest up and see what happens
depends depends on me depends on your
code depends how you feel
good luck tomorrow maxi must of course
this would be your first grand
Chestertown we've come close I'm sure
you're looking forward to it yeah it's
gonna be fun thank you my team and
that's it for us guys here from the
Olympia Centre in London it's been a
great series of classical chess but no
blood was spilled we have to wait until
the rapid and blitz to have a winner
tomorrow that's right we've had 20
straight draws from London now with the
world championship followed by the eight
that's it that's a huge a huge record
and for Fabiano if it goes back to the
Olympiad three so 23 games 19 because he
didn't play all all eight of the
classical here right let's be clear it's
a little unfair to Fabiano he had a
magnificent result of wars he was
crushing people they beat mummy-ji Rob
hippy anon he be Galvan he was dropping
wood in that tournament even won a medal
right for his performance on board one
it's so it's kind of unfair to yeah yeah
yeah
redraws when he was playing into all
these top players in that event and
doing extremely well there one of his
best tournaments as well of the year of
a year of spectacular events that he has
put together in classical chess and he
did draw a Magnus 12 times I mean you
want him to beat Magnus folks
not so easy so I don't think it's fair
to show a lot of draw streak to Fabiano
it is fair to say that is wrapping the
Blitz is not up to that level that his
classical skills are and I think that he
will have trouble tomorrow getting third
place for sure yeah LaVon should win but
you know what that's why we play the
games yes I think it's very close I
think that's exaggerated LeMans edge I
think it's closer to a toss as we say in
poker grain flip with perhaps of on
having right the eights and havi having
the east came there you go
Eastern offsuit of course right that's I
mean hey girls Jack it was so awesome I
wouldn't have picked him at the best
dress of the round because LaVon is
always so sharp right wow that was that
was really awesome
you like the jack yeah that along with
his g6 calculation that wasn't very
bring the calculation but don't forget
the jacket even Maurice as we go into
the final day tomorrow
well it's interesting that the designers
this year of the grand chest or decided
that 2018 will be the year of rapid and
blitz that it emphasized those events
primarily and we had the live in event
we had Paris we had st. Louis rapid and
blitz three events and only one
classical event in the Sinquefield cup
and now it's come down to that emphasis
being the case that it's going to be
decided in rapid inlets and between two
sterling players at this format makes
perfect sense I think tomorrow is going
to be extremely exciting the finals of
course certainly the constellation
matchup we'll keep our eye on but it's
going to be some amazing back and forth
chess between these two fantastic
players absolutely something to watch a
thrill but from two of the best players
in the world so I'm looking forward to
it absolutely Maurice to the best rapid
and blitz players in the world playing
for the grand Chester championship makes
perfect sense to me
so mr. party we'll see you tomorrow at
two o'clock in London
we're gonna start the show at 7:50 here
in st. Louis and that's 8:50 on the East
Coast thank you everyone for joining us
have a great weekend
[Music]
[Music]